ohoo days don't hurt me and my phone
call hello
what you doing Oh what's gonna happen
for me too I'm gonna [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
it's gonna happen you're not supposed to
vlog with your pants on they want to
think that I wear pants
all the time BTS booty that slap on my
block close your doors hot do not close
my damn door
[Music]
Oh what is going on you too if you can't
tell already I'm stubborn as [ __ ] look
at my face and tell me this [ __ ] did not
get real on my epidermis that's right
the skin for you people who don't read
and [ __ ] cuz I know what I'm talking
about
I hate being sunburned and I should've
known who's gonna happen because I am a
fair-skinned asian apparently the Sun
and my favorite creamy skin does not
match up because I got roasted I'm not
even gonna lie I'm so red right now
white people have been observing me from
a distance confused as hell my god he
looks oriental but he burns like one of
us man before this sermon there was only
one youtuber that was more like into my
ass and that [ __ ] was Jason Chen
that's my friend but you damn well know
that boy got the baby skin of a Japanese
geisha you know what time I slept that
fool in the face once as a joke I ain't
gonna lie skin was so tender it felt
like I was faking an infant baby Jason
you must be moisturizing with [ __ ]
unicorn Stephen assumption what's your
secret a lot of Korean girls would like
to know think I don't mind being a
little tan I like color my skin makes me
feel all ethnic and beautiful promise I
was a bad boy now look at me I'm the
[ __ ] same color as my shirt you know
a lot of people don't know this but you
know how like black folk about my skin
problems well Asian people got my skin
problem too
because for some reason in Asian
cultures the more light-skinned you are
the more you'll want it [ __ ] that [ __ ]
racist I want to deal with that I'm a
little gone up your [ __ ] chocolate
tender apparently if you live in Korea
you guys look like you just died
yesterday
oh [ __ ] you yeah you look like a case
for the pretty girls everybody who isn't
Asian think about this what the [ __ ] do
you always see old Asian ladies with
umbrellas in the middle of summer they
try to stay an ice cube for the rest of
that started lives you don't want none
that you berate [ __ ] you ever see
how Asian people treat the dark-skinned
Asian she's a damn shame you walk into a
supermarket darkness [ __ ] all the old
ladies look at you like you a [ __ ]
refugee mother [ __ ] money so talk man
and apparently big bad s sunburn at the
same time is not a good look because all
the [ __ ] kids the park thank you cool
lady [ __ ] [ __ ] you kids I suck in your
face kool-aid you know growing up in
America there's such a different
cultural dynamic when it comes to the
color of your skin because Asian people
do whatever we can to stay light-skinned
but for some reason white people y'all
do whatever you can to get oranges fuch
you have had one white bird in high
school who just learned about tanning
beds and then she just took it way too
far because at a certain point she was
hot but eventually she started looking
like a bluebird sir Luzi hi
oh my god I'm not even kidding you I
knew this girl in high school who did
that [ __ ] that she went for straight
white to mahogany
I just remember this girl was so Brown
when she started doing yoga one day
everybody thought she was in a small
tree with no leaves I got one more night
I bet you I bet you what listen I hate
being sunburned and I should have known
this was gonna happen because I'm a set
hahaha you walk into a supermarket what
the [ __ ] do text me right now you look
like a case for the everybody don't let
him wear pants on my flaws yeah yeah I
do the what time you say I'm so sweaty
right now you get ready no I'm just
doctor you're the same color as a strap
up your bag give me [ __ ] cuz on my pants
whatever is my house the hell out of
here
hey my friend